Lo que queremos hacer en este video es aprender a
construir ángulos congruentes, y lo haremos, por
supuesto, con un bolígrafo o un lápiz. Usaré una
regla y luego usaré una herramienta conocida como
compás, que se ve un poco sofisticada, pero nos
permite al presionarlo un poco dibujar círculos
o arcos perfectos de un radio determinado: nos
apoyamos sobre este pivote de aquí y luego usamos
la pluma o lápiz para trazar el arco o el círculo.
Entonces, comencemos con este ángulo de aquí,
y voy a construir un ángulo que sea congruente
con él. Así que permítanme hacer el vértice del
segundo ángulo justo aquí, y luego voy a dibujar
uno de los rayos que se originan en ese vértice.
Voy a poner este ángulo en una orientación
diferente sólo para mostrar que ni siquiera
tienen que tener la misma orientación, entonces se
verá algo así. Ese es uno de los rayos, pero ahora
tenemos que averiguar dónde colocamos el otro
rayo para que los dos ángulos sean congruentes,
y aquí es donde nuestro compás será realmente
útil. Lo que voy a hacer es colocar el pivote
del compás justo en el vértice del primer ángulo
y voy a dibujar un arco como este. Lo que es útil
acerca del compás es que podemos mantener el
radio constante y pueden ver que interseca los
dos primeros rayos en los puntos, llamémosles B y
C, y llamaremos a este punto A justo aquí. Y ahora
que tengo el compás abierto con el radio exacto
déjenme dibujarlo aquí, esto no nos permitirá
dibujar el ángulo todavía pero primero permítanme
dibujarlo así. Está bastante bien. Llamemos a este
punto D y llamaré a este E, y queremos averiguar
dónde colocar el tercer punto F para poder definir
el rayo EF de modo que estos dos ángulos sean
congruentes. Lo que podemos hacer es tomar el
compás de nuevo y fijar la distancia entre C
y B, ajustando el compás, el pivote está en C
y el lápiz está en B, así que tengo justo esta
distancia. Conozco esta distancia y he ajustado
el compás de manera que pueda obtener esa misma
distancia aquí. Y ahora pueden imaginar dónde
voy a dibujar ese segundo rayo, puedo dibujar el
segundo rayo comenzando en el punto E, justo aquí,
pasando por el punto F -aunque lo puedo dibujar
mejor-, así se vería el segundo rayo. Ignoren
esa primera línea que dibujé, estoy usando un
bolígrafo; no les recomiendo hacer eso. Lo estoy
haciendo así para que puedan verlo mejor en este
video. Ahora, ¿cómo sabemos que este ángulo es
congruente con este ángulo justo aquí? Bueno, una
forma de hacerlo es pensar en el triángulo BAC y
el triángulo llamémoslo DFE, este triángulo justo
aquí. Cuando dibujamos ese primer arco sabíamos
que la distancia entre AC era equivalente a la
distancia entre AB, y mantuvimos el radio del
compás igual. Entonces sabemos que esa es también
la distancia entre EF y la distancia entre ED,
y luego, la segunda vez, cuando ajustamos el radio
del compás, sabíamos que la distancia entre BC era
la misma que la distancia entre F y D, es decir,
la longitud de BC es igual a la longitud FD,
por lo tanto está muy claro que tenemos
triángulos congruentes: los tres lados tienen
la misma medida y, por lo tanto, los ángulos
correspondientes también deben ser congruentes.